okay Neptunian is the first of these
synthetically prepared heavy elements
uranium being the last naturally
occurring element neptunium is as you
might imagine named after the planet
Neptune the naming of elements is
bizarre to say the least
sometimes it's who discovered it
sometimes it's where it was discovered
it has to go to an IU pack naming
committee and there's various of the
rules and regulations which come into it
synthetic in that the sensor it doesn't
naturally occur on earth we've had to
prepare it by taking other heavy
elements and then bombarding them with
various nuclei and what happens when you
bombard a nuclei with another nuclei is
that some bits may stick and some bits
will fall out but what you end up with
is then a new element type so from here
onwards everything has been man-made
none of it naturally occurs and unless
you count naturally-occurring has been
found in the debris of an exploded
nuclear bomb